Biden remains atop the polls bernie
proposes free college and Budaj edge
steps into dicey racial territory i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
and triple-b today
Biden Bernie and Budaj edge how good
times as the debates approach we'll be
getting into all of it shortly first you
know when you're seeking to hire a
president sometimes you make bad
decisions and when you're seeking to
hire an employee sometimes you make bad
decisions too well there is one way that
you can stop making bad decisions this
is where a zip recruiter comes in hiring
used to be hard not anymore
when someone makes the slightest most
minor insignificant mistake here on the
bench Shapiro show they know they can
easily be replaced
thanks to zip recruiter zip records calm
slash daily wire is the way the access
is zip recruiter zip recruiter will send
your job posting to over 100 of the
web's leading job boards they don't stop
there as applications come in zip
recruiter that analyzes each one
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
zip recur is so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip record comm slash at daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly WI re zipper career comm slash at
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to go hire to go check them
out right now don't be saddled with
employees who don't match our
expectations instead go check out zip
recruit comm slash daily wire okay so
the democratic debates approaches the
first one is tomorrow night on CNN whoo
and it's going to feature Elizabeth
Warren and a cast of no names that's the
first debate the first debate is
Elizabeth Warren who is steadily rising
in the polls taking away Bernie Sanders
his support may be rivaling Joe Biden at
the top of the Democratic field and no
one else is on that stage like cory
booker i believe is on that stage and no
one cares no one has any interesting
cory booker no one has any interest in
any of the other candidates it's like
marianne williamson and Eric's wall well
and the cast of thousands the the big
debate is the following tonight the big
debate is Thursday night that's the one
where you get Biden and Budaj edge and
Bernie and it's all party central over
there but tomorrow night is the sort of
more boring debate where Elizabeth
Warren does get her showcase at the same
time she's sort of getting left
she's sort of getting wet particularly
if the second debate elevates into a
Biden versus Bernie fight which is what
everybody sort of foresees at this point
and what Bernie needs to happen right
now if Bernie wants to elevate himself
above Warren he needs to regain control
of the narrative he needs to rest that
control away from Elizabeth Warren who's
receiving these ODEs these pans from the
media they these huge profiles man she
has ideas she has plans so many ideas
and plans weird because Bernie had those
plans first and they were more extreme
as well see Bernie has responded to this
by posing even more extreme plans the
beauty of being in the Democratic Party
is if you're ever short of an idea just
promise to make more things free it's
really simple that way but here is the
current state of the Democratic primary
according to a morning and console poll
and this is actually a little surprising
so according to this morning console
poll Joe Biden remains the heavy
front-runner at 38% in the primaries now
that of course means that he has not
really felt the impact of the hole he
was hanging out with segregationist and
he's racially insensitive and all of
this there's not a lot of evidence
that's damaged him at all in fact these
same poll numbers show that something
like 30 percent of black folks who
supported Joe Biden say they still
support Joe Biden 27 percent said they
don't care and only 20 percent said they
were less likely to support Joe Biden
that's not a significant amount of
movement so Joe Biden is up at 38% which
is precisely where he was a couple of
weeks ago in the morning console poll
which shows that his candidacy is
durable now is it durable enough to
withstand a singular challenger right
now he can hold off a field of 1,000 but
can he hold off a field of 1 this was
the question for Hillary Clinton against
Bernie Sanders this will also be the
question for Joe Biden against
presumably Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders or if Camille harris starts to
get momentum Kamala Harris says we'll
see I think people who to judge is in
serious trouble this early on so Bernie
Sanders is in second place right now
with 19 percent this is also kind of
surprising from the morning consult poll
a lot of the recent polls have showed
that Elizabeth Warren was climbing over
Bernie Sanders for that second place
spot that she was gaining momentum that
Bernie was losing momentum while
Elizabeth Warren is gaining momentum
according to the morning console poll
she's up a couple of points to 13
percent but she's still trailing Bernie
Sanders by 6 in this morning
so pull and they're both far behind Joe
Biden now as I say if you aggregate
together all of the far-left progressive
votes
this isn't much close to race right of
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and
Pete booties edge and Kamala Harris were
all one candidate that candidate would
be receiving their 45% of the vote to
Joe Biden's 38% of the vote Joe Biden
may have a 38% ceiling so that means
that if the field winnows quickly then
Joe Biden could be in trouble if however
the field remains disparate then Joe
Biden just runs right up the center of
the way that Donald Trump did in 2016
and takes the nomination Elizabeth
Warren it's at 13 and then you get to
the also-rans Pete Budaj edge is stuck
at 7% Kamala Harris is stuck at 6% she
really has experienced significant
failure to launch bethe o'rourke all the
way down at 4%
the former darling of the Democratic
Party when he was running against Ted
Cruz I have to to stuck all the way down
at 4% going nowhere fast Cory Booker at
a minuscule 3% Andrew yang my boy Andrew
yang at 2% so I'm kind of happy about
that because Andrew yang I actually
think is a at least a nice person who
doesn't despise everybody who disagrees
with him so that's kind of nice so
Andrew yang at 2% and Michael Bennett
for some reason at 1% kirsten gillibrand
not even charting as always the best
part of this entire story okay so
Elizabeth Warren however is gaining
momentum in one of the more radical
polls so there is a survey from
moveon.org last time around Bernie
Sanders one going away among the
moveon.org crowd he was up at like 80%
among the moveon.org crowd now that's
also because he was pretty much the only
one running against Hillary Clinton it
wasn't like there was a huge field to
choose from well as the moveon.org crowd
and move over to martin O'Malley or
something it was Bernie Sanders or bust
now Elizabeth Warren has seized control
of the moveon.org crowd and this is why
folks think that there's going to be a
significant fade here from Bernie
Sanders according to NBC News senators
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders top
a new straw poll straw poll from the
progressive group moveon.org
illuminating how the packed field of
candidates is coming into focus for more
left-leaning Democratic voters just
before the first debate of the 2020
cycle the poll which was released on
Tuesday and first reported by NBC News
shows Warren is the top choice of 38% of
MoveOn members nationwide the top choice
of voters surveyed in the early voting
states of California Iowa Nevada New
Hampshire and south
Linna so she's all the way up at 38
Bernie Sanders he's all the way down at
17% trailing Elizabeth Warren by 20
points that is a significant drop-off
for Bernie Sanders what happened all the
Bernie bros where's all the enthusiasm
well it seems that the media coverage
really dove it does have an outsized
impact on the moveon.org
crab and that's not surprising there's
actually a study that came out earlier
this week does pretty fascinating what
it showed is that college-educated
liberals were far more politically
polarized and woke than the Democratic
base so the Democratic base is much more
moderate the Democratic base doesn't
have perverse perceptions and
Republicans quite as much they tend to
think that Republicans by and large are
their neighbors and decent people the
politically progressive woke base which
is largely people who are
college-educated liberals who go to
campus and then ensconced themselves in
their cozy echo chamber those people are
the ones who are being pulled by
moveon.org and those are the people who
have been rallying around Elizabeth
Warren it's the kanzen of progressive
ideas mmm so Sanders is all the way down
at 17% VP Biden had 15% that's pretty
amazing and Budaj edge at 12% so joe
biden at nearly matching Bernie
Sanders's numbers among moveon.org crowd
is very very bad news for Bernie Sanders
according to NBC News that Sanders the
Vermont independent would do well in the
progressive groups poll is no surprise
move on backed him officially over
Hillary Clinton in the 2016 Democratic
primary
a majority of MoveOn members at the time
said they preferred him to the former
Secretary of State but the progressives
are gravitating toward like-minded
policy wonk Warren could be another sign
of trouble for Sanders well part of it
is that NBC News keeps calling Warren a
policy wonk her policies are not wonkish
they're very very bad ideas now overall
most Democrats are still not all that
enthused about Elizabeth Warren that the
polling numbers show why Biden is
maintaining at the top of the polls
first of all he does have the benefit of
low expectations everybody expects that
Joe Biden is gonna gaff nearly all the
time and so when he does gaffe everybody
goes oh well that's all Joe over time is
that going to do damage to him I think
it will over time I don't know that that
Joe Biden can maintain I've been saying
all along that I think that Joe Biden's
first day would be his best date now
again I could be wrong maybe he
maintains a 38 maybe he just sweeps in
the nomination Nate silver suggested the
statistician and pollster he suggested
that Joe Biden's chances of winning the
nomination were under 50% now that's as
compared to the field meaning that
anyone else in the field he's gonna be
lower than that then Joe Biden but the
field overall has a better than 50%
chance of defeating Joe Biden I think
that's about right that he has a
plurality chance of being the nominee
but he certainly does not have the
majority chance of being the nominee a
new poll from the AP and NORC Center for
Public Affairs however finds that
Democrats are not nearly as interested
in the intersectional credentials of
many of the candidates as the media are
the media are firmly convinced that they
need an intersectional Kay a woman
somebody who's gay like Budaj edge
somebody is black like Hummel Harris or
Cory Booker that you need somebody who
is going to awaken the intersectional
coalition to fight fight fight against
the majority and all of this but most
Democrats aren't super interested in
that according to the AP which is why
Biden continues to maintain and why
Biden should not be backing down or
cowering at charges that he is quote
unquote racist over old comments that
were not in fact racist the AAP and
North censor they find the Democrats
gave a collective shrug to gender race
and age as factors they are considering
when supporting a candidate instead
democratic registered voters are
yearning for experience in elected
office a whopping 73 percent cited that
as a quality that would make them more
excited about supporting a presidential
candidate that's because they are using
experience in office as a measure of
electability meaning you've been elected
a bunch of times before this means you
are electable and therefore you have a
better chance of defeating Donald Trump
the top priority for Democrats is
defeating Donald Trump now as we've seen
in the past there is a live debate over
whether that's actually a good strategy
for an election whether it is actually
smart to go for the guy who is
considered most electable in 2012
Republicans went for the supposedly most
electable candidate in Mitt Romney and
he proceeded to lose to Barack Obama in
2016 Hillary Clinton was widely
perceived early on as the most electable
Democrat and then she proceeded to lose
to Donald Trump one of the problems with
people who are perceived as electable is
very often they don't generate the kind
of heat necessary to inspire people to
go out to vote that may be true with Joe
Biden he could be falling into a Hillary
Clinton sort of trap here where people
get comfortable people think he's gonna
win
nobody's super enthused but at least
he's
not Trump that didn't work for Hillary
Clinton and you could see something
similar happen for Joe Biden as well 25
candidates of course are running for the
party's nomination and included very
very diverse field but four in ten
Democratic voters said only that they
would be excited about voting for a
woman for president as opposed to 73
percent who said that they were looking
for experience in elected office so here
our candidate qualities that ignite
excitement in Democrats 73% has
experience in elected office then it
drops all the way down to 40 is a woman
38 has served in the military 26 36
percent is younger 26% has experience
running a business
26 percent black 25 percent Latino 20
percent LGBT 20 percent shares your
religious beliefs by the way that shows
you something about the Democratic base
at this point that the same number of
Democrats are interested in a candidate
who shares their religious beliefs as
are interested in a candidate who is
lesbian gay or bisexual or is
transgender seventeen percent say would
be interested in a candidate that be a
priority if the candidate were
transgender yeah that will see how all
of this plays in middle America but
that's why they're they're favoring
Biden at this point now could Biden
start to become the target absolutely
we'll get to one article targeting Joe
Biden in just a second first let me tell
you something about the mattress I sleep
on it's so good that I got that mattress
for my sister for her wedding okay that
mattress is so good that I took a more
expensive mattress in my own home and
moved it out of our room because helix
is just that good when I love an
advertiser's product so much that
actually go out and buy one as a gift
for a relative that means I really
really do love the product that is the
case with helix sleep mattresses helix
sleep has a quiz it takes two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you sleep
on the side on your back hot sleeper
whatever helix can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep calm slash
man take that two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
they'll give you the best sleep of your
life for couples hulex can even split
that mattress right down the middle
providing those individual support needs
and feel preferences for each side
they've got a 10-year warranty you can
try it out for a hundred nights wrist
crease again nothing to lose they'll
pick it up for you if you don't love it
you're gonna love it
helix is offering up to 125 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
and up to 125 bucks off right now at
helix sleep comm slash Bennett's helix
sleep comm slash Ben for up to 125 bucks
that mattress order the mattress is
indeed fantastic
if personalized everything else in your
life why not a personalized mattress
made for you I mean you're gonna spend
half your life on that thing so go check
it out right now
helix sleep comm slash band okay so as i
say joe biden is now the target it's
pretty obvious that he is the target of
me as the front-runner and mat visor
over at the washington post is going
after Joe Biden for being Richie Rich
the headline once the poorest senator
middle-class Joe has reaped millions and
income since leaving the vice presidency
now here's the truth I don't care if
politicians make a lot of money after
they leave office I don't really see the
problem with that to be frank with you
he was the vice president of the United
States it seems to me that him making a
lot of money on speeches you should go
for it I mean if that's what the market
will bear enjoy yourself man but the
media aren't gonna like this very much
they're gonna go with the he has to be a
populist now what's funny about this is
that Elizabeth Warren is a very wealthy
woman Bernie Sanders is not impoverished
none of the top candidates with maybe
the exception of Peabody Judge who I
don't think is worth very much money are
worth a lot of money I mean are worth no
money they're all worth a lot of money
but Joe Biden is gonna be excoriated for
this as we'll see so this article
suggests the georgian-style home once
from the front of a brick version of the
White House once belonged to Alexander
Haig the former Secretary of State
nestled on a wooded lot in McLean the
nearly 12,000 square foot residence
contains five bedrooms and ten bathrooms
marble fireplaces a gym and a sauna
surrounded by Washington elite and
sitting high above the Potomac River
there is undeniable grandeur in the
design of this home said the British
accented agents in a video released when
it went on the market in 2015 this
property makes an imposing statement
with parking for over 20 cars and
creates a perfect setting for the most
lavish of events I do love that they
added that the person who made the real
estate video is British accented that
means that they're evil as we know from
all the movies every every movie villain
ever is actually British this may have
been the residents to a very important
person he continued but I suspect it
will be the home to many more it's
currently home to Joe Biden the house
was purchased for 4.25 million dollars
that's an expensive home in June 2016 by
Mark pine a wealthy venture capitalist
who lives next door to Joe Biden Joe
Biden and his wife Joe have been renting
this house now this is a very cozy
arrangement that we
saw with Barack Obama for example
political backers buying a piece of
property and then cutting sweetheart
deals with politicians they support so
the politicians can live there
Biden points out on the campaign trail
he was often the poorest member of the
US Senate and for at least a decade has
referred to himself as middle class Joe
I've always found this also a bizarre
sort of brag I'm confused as to why
you're not earning a lot of money is a
brag thank you being a poor senator why
is that better than you having earned a
lot of money in the private sector by
being a productive citizen and then
going into public service they the idea
that you are very wealthy and that you
make a lot of money before you join in
the government as opposed to you know
living off the government teat for 40
years I'm not sure why that that's a
worse pitch then I'm middle-class too
poor because I've been working for the
government my entire life since leaving
office however Joe Biden has violated
his own rules he has enjoyed an
explosion of wealth making millions of
dollars largely from book deals and
speaking fees that range to as much as
$200,000 per speech public documents
show as Biden traveled the country
before announcing his presidential
campaign this spring his sponsors
provided VIP hotel suites Town Cars and
professional drivers chartered flights
and travel expense reimbursements that
for some of his appearances reached at
least $10,000 prevent according to
contracts obtained by the post through
public records requests so what so what
I mean it is amazing to me that I have
to become a Joe Biden defender under
these circumstances
so far I've defended Joe Biden from the
scurrilous accusation that he's a
vicious racist and now from the
scurrilous accusation that ooh he spoke
for people who are willing to pay him
money oh it's very bad but listen he's a
progressive so he deserves whatever he
gets from his progressive base and this
is a guy who's railed against people who
are wealthy suggesting that they should
pay more taxes to be patriotic we can
see how much Joe Biden paid in taxes
over the past few years maybe he should
pay more in taxes The Washington Post
found at least 65 instances in which
Abidin gave a speech or appeared at a
book event in at least 10 of those
instances he did not take a fee though
he was reimbursed for travel expenses
Biden's campaign said he has given less
than 50 paid speeches but declined to be
more specific about exactly how many he
delivered or how much he earned in total
Biden's campaign declined to comment on
the record for this story they've taken
care to avoid the backlash that haunted
Hillary during the 2016 Democratic
primary because she gave private
speeches to Goldman
and other Wall Street and other Wall
Street interests he only limited his
appearances to less politically
sensitive venues public documents show
Biden has been renting the McLean home
he purchased another 2.7 million dollar
forty eight hundred square foot vacation
house near the water in Delaware to go
along with his primary residence the
nearly seven thousand foot square-foot
lakeside home he built more than two
decades ago in Wilmington Delaware so
this is his third home so he's living it
up man Joe Biden really enjoying himself
in his post vice presidency time now I
don't again I don't really think that
this matters very much but for Democrats
who hate wealth and think that being
wealthy means that you are now evil I
guess that this is a bad thing so Joe
Biden is gonna feel the the impact of
all of this a review of his previous tax
returns show the Biden's adjusted gross
income at $215,000 in 1998 the first
year he has made available and remained
in that neighborhood until 2009 buy
Biden's final years in office the
couple's gross income totaled about
three hundred ninety thousand dollars
annually and they donated nearly nothing
to charity for the ten years preceding
2008 they donated an average of 369
bucks annually to charity is one of the
beautiful things about being a Democrat
it means never having to give charity it
really is delightful to be a Democrat
calling for everybody else to be
patriotic and give more money to the
government also here is the change I
found in my couch cushions and I'm going
to give this to a charity for an average
of three hundred sixty-nine dollars
annually to charity there was never a
point in my adult life where I gave that
kind of money to charity I mean I was
making way less money than Joe Biden was
here and I was given more than that and
and I am NOT the ideal of charity there
people give way more in charity than I
do the total increase when Biden served
as VP with donation of Book proceeds to
charity clothing to Goodwill and other
contributions the 2015 forms Joe he has
taken out a mortgage on his Delaware
home in 2013 he also took out a line of
credit on his home the next year his
Delaware estate became the source of
income for several years so they there
they're doing well they're doing well in
April of 2017 he signed a book deal that
was worth eight million dollars covering
three books to buy the VP and one from
Joe Biden two of those books have been
published to date so high income Joe
high net worth
Joe doesn't have the same sort of ring
as his middle class Joe and we'll see
how Democrats try to exploit that saying
that Biden is out of touch that'll be
the pitch right Biden is out of touch on
issues of race he's old and now they're
gonna say he's out of touch with the
common man because he's rich it'll be
amusing to watch the fellow progressives
make him there they're targeting their
their their target it'll be very amusing
to watch that frankly it is incredible
to watch how far left the Democratic
Party has moved I mean Joe Biden was on
the progressive wing of the Democratic
Party for many years just as Nancy
Pelosi was the leader of the progressive
wing of the Democratic Party in Congress
for many many years until AOC arose at
which point Nancy Pelosi became a
moderate the fact that Joe Biden
is now considered the moderate in the
Democratic Party is pretty astounding it
is a pretty astounding thing in just a
second we'll get to Bernie Sanders who's
been stumbling along the way and thus he
has announced his new strategy free crap
for everyone my free crap for everyone
he means that you and I will pay for the
free crap he wants to give people in
return for their votes
bribery with taxpayer dollars fun and
lucrative I'll get to that in just one
second first would you like to win a
free gun I mean hell who wouldn't if
you're a law-abiding citizen and you're
somebody who knows how to use a gun you
should own a gun if you answered yes
listen up this is your last chance did
you do just that I've teamed up with the
United States concealed-carry
Association to give you the opportunity
to win awesome guns gear and
self-defense guides daily this is the
last chance to get 7 free chances to win
1234 dollars just for texting in our
Pete you could win
1234 dollars the exact amount you need
to buy a beautiful new 1911 just for
texting in there is no catch as always
your information is kept safe text the
word win - 87 - 2 - to see the gun and
lock in your seven free chances to win
the u.s. ECA is committed to helping
responsibly armed Americans that's why
they offer giveaways like this but you
need to hurry because it all ends on
this Friday June 28th text win - 87 - 2
- right this moment
- enter and as an extra bonus the first
2000 people tenser also will be sent at
you SEC a concealed carry guide
completely free by the way it's a great
organization next win 287 - - to get
your seven entries and free concealed
carry guide text win 287 - - to WI n 287
- 2 - okay so Bernie's
looks to be on the ropes in this
campaign he's dropping in the polls he's
holding steady and a few of them at
around 20% but he is certainly nowhere
near too challenging Joe Biden in
supremacy in these polling numbers he's
basically getting doubled up by Joe
Biden or surpassed by Elizabeth Wharton
and that means that Bernie Sanders has
to announce pre stuff the time has come
it's time for Bernie Sanders to announce
recess so yesterday he announced that he
wants to cancel the entirety of all
student loan debt in the United States
and presumably also going forward so
this is gonna cost like three trillion
dollars he says that he wants to spend
1.6 trillion dollars right now the case
that he made on Twitter was if we can
bail out Wall Street then we should be
able to bail out student loans I love
that kind of logic if we can do this
thing that no one liked and everyone
thought was bad then we can also do this
non sequitur great argument here is
Bernie Sanders yesterday on the lawn on
CNN telling all the younger people first
got off my lawn second time paying off
your student loans this proposal will
make it possible for every person in
America to get all of the education they
need regardless of their financial
status this means making public colleges
universities and HBCUs tuition-free and
debt-free by tripling the work-study
program expanding Pell grants and other
financial incentives okay so we're going
to just pay off everybody student loans
now there are a million reasons this is
a crap idea reason number one
disproportionately the people with
student loans are people who are middle
income and higher income or who will be
because they have college degrees so you
are now creating a regressive tax system
whereby people who have either already
paid off their student loans or people
who didn't take student loans are paying
for people who did take student loans
second you're incentivizing people to go
to college without regard to their
financial situation and that's really
stupid because the fact is that very
often if you're going to college to
major in art history and to cost
$150,000 that's not a good deal for you
and it's not a good deal for the
taxpayer you should be going to college
to learn a trade and banks are
great way of telling you what exactly
they think you're going to make coming
out of college you can take out those
loans but banks may charge you a higher
interest rate depending on your major if
this were all privatized one of the
great tragedies of the American higher
educational system is the subsidization
of individual choice in education by the
taxpayer so the the you know we're not
talk about mandatory education now we're
not talk about school vouchers for
seventh graders who have to go to a
school we are talking about people going
to college to major in random crap that
they completely don't need and doing so
on the back of people who are already
earning the taxpayer dollars many of
whom are not going to college and this
is not a rip by saying that that only
dumb people don't go to college or
something like that that's silly
I know a thousand smart people who
didn't go to college and I know a
thousand smart people who did go to
college but probably didn't need to go
to college my business partner went to a
community college for two years and
dropped out he's doing fine he runs a
business that employs a hundred people
hey this is you don't have to go to
college to be highly successful by
proclaiming that you do and that the
taxpayer should foot the bill we're
engaged in something dumb the reality is
that many other countries that heavily
subsidize higher education also do
what's called tracking in Israel they
subsidize higher education they also
track the students at age 17 18 years
old and basically you are tracked into
engineering or you are tracked into some
other field and that way the government
basically knows that they're getting
their worth out of you Bernie Sanders on
the other hand would simply like to
throw everybody into Lokanath Studies at
the University and then have you paid
for it and me pay for all so what a
sucker I was and my goodness what a
sucker I was so I took out a bunch of
student loan debt to go to Harvard Law
School and then I proceeded to pay off
all of my student loan debt and then I
paid for the end of my wife's college
education and I paid for her entire
medical school education and we paid for
that because we're married and we are
suckers man we should have just waited
around in fact I want student loan
reparations I was sucker enough to pay
back the government if she took a Pell
Grant which I don't remember Franklin
I was certainly sucker enough to pay
back the banks that made us the loans I
feel like I deserve reparations from
Bernie Sanders if we're gonna do this
and everybody who fairly paid their debt
ought to be paid also why is it only the
people who didn't pay their debt who
ought to be paid so the more
irresponsible
or with your debt in taking it out and
then not paying it back the more I'm
supposed to pay for it even though I
already did my job by paying back my
debt here's the thing monetary
incentives help you structure your
decision-making in a more beneficial way
if you think that there are no
consequences to your actions you are
very likely to take more irresponsible
actions responsibility comes with
consequences I took yesterday on my
radio show about the difference between
carefree and free Bernie Sanders seems
to identify the two the idea is that he
wants you to be true freedom he says
comes from economic security no true
true carefree feeling it comes from
economic security true freedom comes in
living like an adult where you bear the
consequences of your actions
this actually incentivizes you to take
more responsible actions Bernie Sanders
wants to disincentivize all of that
Bernie Sanders would like for everyone
to have no incentive to be responsible
and you can see how this thinking leads
to utter silliness so the venerable
Alexander Ocasio Cortez who is just a
Jew a crown jewel of intellect in the
United States Congress she was out there
yesterday stumping for Bernie Sanders
his dumb plan and she says that she told
the very very sad story a very sad story
about a girl who got into a dream
college but she couldn't afford to go I
mean my heart wept my heart wept I was
mentoring this girl that this young
woman her name was Ann today as she was
about three or four years younger than
me and she had gotten into all of these
prestigious universities but she was
given no student loan assistance and she
truly felt at sixteen seventeen years
old
she felt that the decision of college
was so important that she felt that she
needed to consider taking on two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars worth of debt
to go to college and I think that in and
of itself illustrates the absurdity of
our education financing system and that
is wrong it is not right okay I have a
question why is it wrong so she had to
consider whether to take out debt to pay
for an education that would presumably
give her a calling card so she could
make more money afterward and then pay
back to that this is how loans work when
you take out a mortgage for a house it's
because you think that the house is
either going to accrue in value or
are you're going to pay off the mortgage
you don't just take on like you know my
dream houses my dream house is Joe
Biden's current house that sounds like a
great house right 12,000 square feet 4.5
million dollars on the open market
sounds pretty fantastic you know what
I'm not gonna do go buy that house not
only because Joe Biden is living there
and might go out on a balcony and shoot
a shotgun into the air or something but
also because I can't afford that house
right why would I go and buy a house I
can't afford making responsible
financial decisions is part of being an
adult you know I have lots of dreams I
have a dream that the media will
objectively cover aoc stupidity that's
not going to happen either right not all
dreams come true reality doesn't fulfill
all of our dreams but it seems to me
that suggesting that there's something
broken in our finance system there is by
the way something broken in our Student
Loan and finance system and that is the
involvement of the federal government in
the first place which has led to a
radical increase in the number of people
trying to get new into college which has
led to a radical increase in the number
of administrators not a radical increase
in supply and thus a rising price that's
dramatically rising prices in the
student loan markets despite and not
despite because of federal subsidies
that's why you're seeing these rising
prices but if the idea is that this poor
girl achieved got into a college and
then had to take out student debt which
presumably she will then pay off maybe
she should assess whether it is worth
the debt or not the fact that we take it
for granted that it is worth the debt to
go to college is very silly it's very
silly we do this all the time in our
lives and but you wouldn't do this with
a mortgage you wouldn't you wouldn't do
it with any other form of debt you
wouldn't say listen my dream is to own
that enormous house right there and so
I'm taking on four million dollars of
debt on a $100,000 salary you wouldn't
do that cuz this would make you a fool
why people do it with college it's just
because there's been alive that's been
promulgated by our media and our
politicians that if you go to college
you are instantly guaranteed a
six-figure income when you come out no
matter what garbage' major in and it's
silly and it's stupid and it's
counterproductive okay in just a second
I'll show you more foolish lines of
thought from illustrious members of our
Congress on student loans but first let
me tell you about the best suit that I
own the best suit that I own is an
endowed Chino suit it was customized it
was made just for me there's no reason
for you to buy a suit off the rack just
go get a fantastic personalized suit
from endo Chino
they make suits shirts your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort I mean these are
good-looking suits they have an
attention to detail you're just not
gonna find it department stores if
you're in the middle of planning a
wedding they have tons of options for
people looking to outfit their wedding
party they have a wide selection of high
quality fabrics and colors to choose
from plus the option to personalize the
details including your lapel your lining
pockets buttons writing your own
monogram here's how it works you can
visit a stylist at one of their
showrooms or you can measure at home and
shop online at endo chino comm choose
your fabric and design customizations
simply submit your measurements with
your choices online and then it can sit
back and relax while your suit gets
professionally tailored and then mailed
to you in a couple of weeks this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 369 bucks at Indo chinos
calm when you enter Shapiro's at
checkout that's 50% off the regular
price for a made to measure premium suit
plus shipping is free
that's endo chino comm promo code
Shapiro for any premium suit for just
369 bucks and free shipping
it's an incredible deal for a premium
made to measure so you go check it out
right now
once you go custom you're not gonna go
back look like James Bond not like the
schlub in the real estate commercial go
check them out right now at ENSO chinos
calm and use promo code Shapiro for any
premium suit just 369 bucks okay where
to get to more on student loans and then
we're gonna get to Joe Biden who
continues to fight back against Bernie
Sanders we'll see if he succeeds and
Pete Budaj running into some trouble get
to all that first you have to go
subscribe over at daily where to come go
to that $9.99 a month you've heard that
repeal before 99 bucks a year gets you
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels tester eyes upon it and despair
that you have it not but you could go
check it out right now over at Daley
wire.com and please join the team it
really helps us bring you the show every
day
it helps insulate us from the
vicissitudes of people on the Left who
are interested in taking down the show
helps us make sure that we can pay the
venerable people who work here so go
check us out over a daily wire.com we
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in America
[Music]
you
okay ALC wasn't just telling sad stories
about others no AOC had a sad story
about AOC a very sad story about AOC
despite the fact that a OC is the
youngest elected member of Congress
despite the fact that a OC is completely
unqualified for her position on an
intellectual or governmental level
despite the fact that AOC earns close to
180 thousand dollars a year and lives in
a luxury apartment in Washington DC
she's a victim don't you know and she's
a victim because she has student loan
debt just like a lot of people she has
student loan debt and this means that
she has been victimized by the system
the system's bad how do we know the
system is bad listen to her case for why
the system is bad and I let's see if you
can spot the logical flaw in what she's
saying I will be completely honest I
will disclose my my personal stake in
this fight because I have student loans
too and I think it's so funny a year ago
I was waiting tables in a restaurant and
it was literally easier for me to become
the youngest woman in American history
elected to Congress than it is to pay
off my student loan debt okay she is so
unbelievably whiny I'm sorry this is
stop stop bitching for a second I mean
stop complaining like that's so
unbelievably whiny hey I have student
loans at poor little me and therefore
bail me out I mean talk about a
privileged mentality I voluntarily took
out student loan debt and then I used my
college degree to brag about how smart I
am because I have a degree in
international relations where apparently
I learned things like Jeremy Corbyn is
wonderful and we have concentration
camps on the border and also I have a
minor in economics where I learned
things like capitalism is very bad and
also it's some sort of oppression to
grow certain types of vegetables in
Brooklyn or something and then she
stands around talking oh poor little aoc
oh oh the heart weeps ah we all have to
so if her contention is that it was
easier for her to get elected to
Congress than to pay off her student
loan debt this is an excellent case for
her not being in Congress it's an
excellent case and I will tell you why
if you are unable to pay off your
student loan debt I have a proposal if
you are unable or unwilling to pay off
your student loan debt you should not be
a representative in the public sphere
number one you got skin in the game and
you're bailing yourself out so if you're
bailing yourself out that's not great
that's not a great thing
cuz here we're not talking about you
keeping more of your own money we're
talking about you being forgiving debt
that you voluntarily took out she's
basically Michael Scott in the office
running out in public shouting I declare
bankruptcy it's ridiculous like if you
can't pay for your student loan debt
don't take it out and also your voters
should know that like really if it was
easier for you to be elected to Congress
than to pay off your student loan debt
that doesn't say a lot about you
maybe you should have worked on paying
off your student loans out like a
responsible human being by the way how
much of that one hundred one hundred
seventy-five thousand dollars to be in
Congress which is basically a part-time
job doesn't sound bad to me seems like
you could pay your student loan debt off
right now instead of asking me to pay
off your student loan debt lady really
ridiculous okay and then finally we have
Ilhan Omar so Ilhan Omar who may or may
not have once married her brother this
is still under dispute according to the
Minneapolis star-tribune
she says that don't worry guys don't
worry student loans that this isn't to
give away to the rich we need to do it
right now it's not a giveaway to the
rich to give a bunch of people who
graduated college and voluntarily took
out that forgiveness for their loans as
opposed to you know low-income people
who have to take out loans from payday
lenders and stuff no we should
definitely make sure that people who
graduated from Harvard with $200,000 in
debt that they are their loans must be
paid off that's not a giveaway to the
rich says L hon Omar what my bill does
is simple as it is revolutionary as
senator Sanders says it cancels all of
1.6 trillion
student loan debt no exceptions no
questions asked full cancellation you
might ask why full cancellation what
about the people who can pay off their
student debt well let me say this the
children of Donald Trump aren't asking
or taking out student loans cancelling
student debt is a problem of the poor
and the middle class not of the rich ok
that's absolute utter horse-pucky
it's absolute nonsense you know the
reason it's absolute nonsense
because many rich people do take out
student loan debt specifically because
they want their kids to have to pay off
the debt hey also many people take out
student loan debt because the student
loans are actually really low interest
rate so it doesn't make a lot of sense
to pay cash
PocketNow when you could incur a low
interest rate over time also the idea is
that you have increased or earning
potential by going to college the
question isn't where you rich when you
went into college and took out the loan
debt the question is are you richer
coming out because that was the whole
bargain wasn't it is that you were gonna
have a higher earning potential and
therefore you can pay off the debt none
of this makes any sense but that's okay
doesn't have to make sense it's free
stuff for everybody yeah Democrats don't
you feel more free I feel more free
knowing that there are a bunch of
Democrats who are gonna come to my house
with a gun if I don't pay taxes to pay
for aoc student loan debt makes me feel
more free I can tell you that and here
in herein lies the pitch for Joe Biden
right in the end here's the pitch for
Joe Biden Joe Biden said yesterday
listen I'm not saying free stuff for
everybody that this is a revolutionary
statement in modern American politics
it's truly incredible but here's Joe
Biden the thing is that the idea as we
strengthen the african-american
community throughout this new country
what we do is we not only make it better
for them we make it better for all of
America and to those people who are
cynical about this I want to point out
we save billions of dollars in the
process billions of dollars and look Rev
we can do this we're not I'm not making
these numbers up mine or not let's make
everything free for everybody all the
time
we can send everybody to Community
College for free cutting in half the
cost of college by just adding six
billion dollars per budget he sounds
like he sounds like a moderate simply
because he says I'm not gonna make
everything free so that that's where all
this comes in now what's fascinating
about the current race is that when you
look at the racial breakdown among the
Democrats it really is fascinating Joe
Biden has a heavy share of the black
vote and this is why he is off to such a
strong start if you look at his share of
the white vote it actually ain't great
he's running absolutely competitively
with Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
among white Americans among black
Americans he is way the hell ahead he
has something like 40% of all the black
vote in the Democratic primaries which
means that he walks away with the
nomination and there been attacks on
Biden over race rate on áhis e-codes was
out there saying that Joe Biden
shouldn't be the nominee al Sharpton who
for some reason is still considered an
expert that people are looking to for
moral guidance despite the fact that he
is one of the worst race baiters in
modern American history and a garbage
heap of a human being the man who who
was
originally made famous by the Tawana
Brawley hoax a man who is deeply
anti-semitic you know pinback your
yarmulkes and come on over to my house
he said right before the Crown Heights
riots of 1991 shouting about diamond
merchants right before Freddie stash
markets burned down in the 1990s this
guy is considered somebody that
everybody has to go visit and pay homage
to all sharp and a terrible human being
well al Sharpton last night said that
Joe Biden needs to apologize for
suggesting that he has to work with
people with whom he disagrees including
in the past segregation of senators here
is how Sharpton ripping on him it's had
no effect whatsoever none that you're
sensitive and that you regard the read
and respect the feelings of people that
you want to govern and say you know I
can grow and I can learn that if I make
a mistake even if it's unintentional I
could say that's a mistake I'm sorry if
I hurt somebody there but let's move on
and bring the country together to
normalize and act like there's some kind
of civil engagement with people that
were advocating outright racist and and
bigoted views to civilize are normalized
that is painful you can't give comfort
to racism and you got to admit and own
when you say something that may be
insensitive to others but it's having no
impact on Joe Biden none among the
voting electorate it's having none okay
and part of that is because the sort of
aura of Barack Obama is on Joe Biden
right Barack Obama the most popular
figure in American politics among black
Americans for obvious reasons first
black president would do that you would
imagine that has affected Joe Biden in a
pretty serious way and that means that
even Cory Booker's attacks on Joe Biden
basically backfired according to the New
York Times so Cory Booker has not gained
in the polls he's been backing off of
his battle deliberately with Joe Biden
so that is you know that's telling at
the same time the racial attacks are
working on people who to judge so Pete
Buddha judge who was until 5 seconds ago
the darling of the media when they
decided to change their allegiance from
Buddha judge to Elizabeth Warren
wholesale no Pete Buddha judge has been
confronted by angry protesters in South
Bend Indiana after a black man who was
allegedly breaking into cars was
confronted by police turned around
allegedly was carrying a knife there's
no dashcam
footage or camera footage from body
armor or anything from the police and a
new shot by a police officer holding a
knife allegedly that's all the available
evidence just because there's a lack of
tape does not mean that there is a
falsification of evidence it just means
there's no evidence from the tape so
that's what we know well Peabody judge
went back to South Bend Indiana to deal
with this and then he just got
shellacked by his own citizens and the
media are burying him let's give him a
moment okay okay so hold on mayor when I
go man got killed over there ran over at
the stoplight what did you say what did
you say mere new gang they're bleeding
how can we supposed to trust you these
people is unheard that's why they are
getting over you asking y'all how can we
trust you when we get retaliate against
are fighting against y'all how can we
trust them okay so the view went after
him wholesale yesterday and I think that
this is indicative of where the
Democratic mindset is going with people
to judge the the the party's over the
thrill is gone
here it's Joy Behar going after people
who judge fix what's going on in South
Bend I think they have 100,000 people
there is something yeah I don't know
very it's small somebody light on you in
your ear buddy it's a small population
do your job first there and then run for
president he has had a problem with the
african-american community in South Bend
for quite some time you have to feel the
community's pain yeah you're
representing yeah and I thought he did a
really piss-poor job of listening to
those people in that town hall and
feeling that they let him know okay so I
mean people are upset with people and
it's not just the view CNN's Jackie
Kucinich yesterday said boo to judge
can't even name is black supporters mean
he's in trouble here The Daily Beast
Hannah Trudeau has a story today about
talking with African American leaders
and he was asked during these private
meetings who are your black supporters
back home who can you name and he
couldn't give them an answer and it was
an answer that he gave to several people
that that she spoke to so that in
itself not being able to answer that
question is problematic and it's making
some of these folks that Hannah spoke to
think that he's not serious and that is
kind of naive about his interactions
with the african-american community and
this what's going on in South Bend is
underscoring that right now so the
attack is still useful but it's only
working on Buddha judge not on Biden why
because Buddha Church is an unknown
Biden has a long history people have
already made up their minds about Joe
Biden and this in essence is his
greatest strength people already have an
opinion of Joe Biden he was the vice
president for eight years he is 100%
baked in kind of like Trump that means
that most attacks on him are going to
fail so that means that it's not about
making Joe Biden into a 15 percent
candidate he's never gonna be a 15
percent candidate it's about tearing him
down to 25 percent 20 percent if you get
him down to 25 he's not he's not the the
nominee because what you're gonna start
seeing is some of these Democrats start
to drop out over time remember we are a
year and a half out guys I mean it is
June of 2019 the first primaries are not
until what the beginning of February of
2020 so we are a solid six to seven
months away from the first primaries
that means that there are gonna be some
of these candidates who drop out their
support is gonna go other places
Biden's gonna have to outlast a lot of
folks if his ceiling is really 38% and
we don't know where his floor is let's
say that his floor is somewhere in the
20s this could turn into a competitive
race still because the best thing for
Elizabeth Warren right now is for people
to judge to fall apart if you're the
last person standing in the progressive
Lane you are the chief rival to Joe
Biden and then it's on then it's on
already time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like so if you are a fan of the
John wick series as you all know I think
that John wick in retrospect some of the
great movies in the history of mankind
the first 15 minutes of John wick 3 is
just nothing but pure wonder and joy
there is a movie that was made back in
2011 is an Indonesian film and was
directed by Gareth Edwards who has gone
on to direct the the 2014 Godzilla which
actually is a really good film it's very
underrated the movie is called the raid
it's effectively die hard with karate
basically it is the entire premise is
that there's a criminal who lives on the
top building of this
the top floor of this building and the
cops go in and they have to get to the
top floor of the building dodging all of
the criminals who live in the building
and are directed by the criminal at the
top that's the entire movie and it's a
great elevator pitch right I mean any
movie that you can sum up and what John
wick is like that they killed this puppy
he kills everyone that's the entire
movie right that this is the raid is
like that except it's got some of the
best shot and directed action sequences
I've ever seen I mean this is really
well choreographed stuff here's a little
bit of the preview we won't play too
much of it because it's in a foreign
language so for the audio listeners it's
not going to give you much there's 20
elite one ruthless crime lord
30 floors of chaos that's it that's the
entire pitch guys and the the action
sequences are just terrific you've seen
some of these actors and other things so
the guy who is sort of the breakout star
from this ended up playing one of the
parts in in the force awakens actually
in rogue one sorry in rogue one he ends
up playing one of the sort of jujitsu
masters and in rogue one the movie is
really fun it's really good I look
forward to watching the raid too it's
really funny so I'm a friend who works
over at Vox I'm Jane Carson and Jane and
I disagree on an enormous amount about
politics but we have very similar taste
in movies and we were agreeing that this
is one of the great films in the history
of film the raid so go check it out it's
available I believe on Netflix certainly
it's available for rent on Amazon if
you're into good action flicks that are
completely mindless this definitely
ranks it's pretty it's pretty phenomenal
okay time for some things that I hate
okay so the suppression of speech
continues apace yesterday James O'Keefe
and his group / Project Veritas
Unleashed video that showed a Google
insider talking specifically about how
Google has been manipulating its search
results how top members of the Google
brass are interested in preventing
another Trump election in 2020 and so
they've been manipulating things from
behind the scenes the amount of trust in
social media is declining rapidly and
thanks to videos like this it definitely
should here's a little bit of what it
sounded like you're a highly biased
political machine
that is bent on never letting somebody
like don't come to power again
- Jen Jen eyes the head of responsible
innovation at Google and she's making
the case that you can't break up Google
because if you have too many small
companies then those small companies
won't be able to police and stop Trump
in 2020 the same way that they couldn't
stop Trump in 2016 I mean this is this
is ugly stuff and this is going to grow
we're gonna see more of this because
basically the Democrats the Republicans
are militating I think you know wrongly
in terms of government tactics but the
Republicans at least are militating in
favor of these platforms being open
Democrats are trying to threaten these
companies they're gonna break them up
unless they shut down speech they don't
particularly like in the headline /
huffington post as we speak right now is
all about shareholders at MasterCard
trying to get MasterCard to refuse to
work with companies the to work with
people they don't like now there are a
lot of people I don't like that these
people also don't like white supremacist
for example but the Orwellian idea of
having credit card companies and banks
you're starting to see the sue banks and
credit card companies declines to do
business not with violent organizations
that's one thing or organizations that
sponsor violence or they violate the law
but with organizations that express
opinions they don't like so what are we
now going to have credit cards that are
available by every different political
orientation so now if you voted for
Donald Trump you won't be able to use
MasterCard is that where this is going
the reason I say that is not because
this is a slippery slope argument I
think that you can prevent white
supremacist without preventing Trump
supporters but I don't think the left is
gonna hold by that because the Left
conflates everyone the hard left says
I'm a white supremacist even though I
hate white supremacists think they're
evil they threaten my life on a regular
basis and I have full-time security
because of them so do I trust these
folks to draw the lines no I don't trust
these folks to drug lines Huffington
Post says four months MasterCard has
tried to suffocate the creation of an
internal committee that would monitor
payments to white supremacist and
far-right extremists CA they're already
broadening it out but on Tuesday
renegade shareholders will finally force
a vote on the matter during the
company's annual share
meeting like most credit card companies
MasterCard is hesitant to surrender
profits by blocking violent white
supremacist from using its services
unless laws are being broken notice the
coverage here from Huffington Post
violent white supremacist unless laws
are being broken well which is it if
they're violent the law is being broken
so they're not violent are they
MasterCard currently processes payments
for several extremist groups including
the League of the South National Policy
Institute proud boy Stormfront V dare
identity Europa Occidental descent and
radix Journal according to Color of
Change I don't like any of those
organizations that does not mean that we
can withstand a climate in which the
left gets to decide which companies get
to work with which groups even if those
groups are not breaking the law so now
that this is the next attempt the next
type is gonna get banks to shut down
people and it starts with people you
don't like and pretty soon they're
working on people you do it's all good
times it's all good times sorry a quick
correction on the raid I my producers
telling me it was Gareth Evans who
directed the radio he's governor Edwards
who directed Godzilla my bad
okay in any case back to the topic at
hand so when it comes to when it comes
to the attempts to use major companies
to shut down people who you don't like
this is truly dangerous to America's
discourse and it kills all trust you're
gonna end up with really radicalized
politics simply because if you're banned
from using certain types of credit card
where you gonna go to the credit card
that presumably will take you is why I'm
not in favor of deep platforming defeat
ideas in the realm of ideas don't try to
ban ideas ban violence fight violence
don't ban ideas even ideas that I think
are crappy and by the way I've been
targeted by these folks far more than
anybody writing for The Huffington Post
and it ain't close ok other type of
things that I hate today so the media
are asking themselves why they're not
covering the allegations of a Jean Carol
more using Carol as the gossip columnist
who claims the back in the 1990s Donald
Trump forcibly raped her
it's the most serious accusation against
Trump so the media are trying to lump
this in with all of the other
allegations against Trump because
they're 16 there are 21 other
allegations against President Trump
depending on the numbers that you use
some of those allegations range from he
kissed me it forcibly kissed me in a
closet - he tried to touch my genitals
or did touch my genitals
is the most serious allegation because
it is an allegation of forcible
penetrative rape and she suggests that
Donald Trump took her into a dressing
room at a Bergdorf and then forcibly
raped her I mean forcibly penetrated her
so this is by far the most serious
allegation and you can take all these
allegations seriously and say as I have
said for a very long time that President
Trump has a long record of being garbage
with women which he does and still say
that you still have to take each
allegation as per the allegation so I
think many of the allegations about him
forcibly kissing women for example those
seem incredible to me I can't say I
think that this allegation does not
raise significant red flags and the
reason that it doesn't racing that I
think it raises significant red flags
the behavior of II Jean Carol here does
not be speak a level of credibility she
took a picture on the cover of New York
magazine wearing the jacket she says the
president Trump raped her in she says
she refuses to turn it over to police
for DNA analysis so we can determine
whether that is true or not she said
yesterday that she would not actually be
attempting to push prosecution because
it would distract from rape at the
border or something and then yesterday
she suggested she did something so
bizarre on Anderson Cooper on CNN that
Anderson Cooper had to randomly cut to a
commercial it was really it was bizarre
it was weird it undercuts credibility it
does go to credibility and you have to
assess credibility you have to take
allegation seriously and then you have
to assess the evidence and the
credibility it doesn't make you look
credible when you say things like this
on CNN you don't feel like a victim
I was not throwing on the ground and
ravish which the more raped carries so
many sexual connotations this was not
this was not sexual but just it hurt it
just what it just you know I think most
people think of rape and as I mean it is
a violent assault it is not I think most
people think of rapists being sexy let's
take a short break in the fantasies hmm
we've gotta take a quick break or if you
can stick around we'll talk more on the
other side Anderson Cooper Anderson
Cooper sinking into the ground trying to
escape via commercials producers in his
ear right there you can tell the signs
of it I mean that's make your judgment
for yourself but it is amazing to watch
the media pretend
that the allegations by this woman are
as substantiated as some of the other
allegations against Trump and these are
much more serious allegations than some
of the other allegations I mean there is
a level of seriousness that attends to
penetrative forcible rape that is not
quite the same as he grabbed my face and
kissed me and kissed me on the lips at a
public event which are some of these
other allegations nonetheless here's
chris cuomo you know saying that this is
super it's super important how why are
we just brushing her off as just one
more that's the point you can't brush
her off as just one more you have to
assess the allegations on their own
merit what the Democrats and many in the
media are trying to do is wrap this all
up into a ball and say okay well if he
did the X and he did why who may have
done why I don't know you don't know
nobody knows except for eg and Carroll
and Trump presumably but if the
allegation is that he has done a lot of
things before therefore he did this
thing you know in court
we don't actually allow that evidence of
past crimes is not actually admissible
in court specifically because you're
supposed to assess whether a thing
occurred on the basis of whether the
thing occurred here is Chris Cuomo
though saying that we shouldn't just
brush this one off
no one's brushing it off but you do have
to listen to what the lady's saying and
she is not helping herself here this
prominent journalist accuses the sitting
president of rape this is the most
extreme accusation we've had against
this president and it has had almost no
impact really on our dialogue if people
are so appalled by this president's
nonchalance and the wild number of women
who say they were attacked or assaulted
or in this case raped why isn't this
most serious account to date when others
were car covered in large ways why is
this not front-page news okay the answer
is it's not information whose really
because this lady has undercut her own
credibility a bunch of times and that's
the real answer the real answer is this
was this would be front-page news if she
weren't going on national television and
suggesting that she's not prosecuting
because she doesn't want to distract
from rape at the border it would be
front-page news if she weren't coming
off a book next week after saying
silence on this thing for 20 years
despite the fact that Trump was a public
figure in the 1990s remained a public
figure all the way up to his presidency
and was hit with a wave of these
allegations in 2016 and it would be
front-page news if she weren't going on
Anderson Cooper and then saying that
rape is sexy and that she doesn't she
says I wasn't thrown on the ground
that hers that is her actual allegation
her actual allegation is that she was
grabbed by the arms that Trump held her
against a wall and then ravished her
right and then raped her that is her
actual allegation you got to actually
look at the evidence in these cases
before you decide whether or not this
actually this particular instance and
that doesn't undercut the generalized
argument about what President Trump is
with women but the reason people are not
taking this allegation with the same
seriousness as some of the others in
2016 is because frankly some allegations
are more credible than others this one
seems less credible to most people I
think that there's a reason why that is
and it's not simply political
partisanship okay we will be back here a
little bit later today with a couple
additional hours of content or we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 Bernie Sanders proposes that tax
payers pay off every single student loan
in the country we will explain how
student loan forgiveness is welfare for
the rich then the woman accusing
president Trump of rape describes rape
as sexy finally the United States might
go to war with Iran
we'll explain it all on the Michael
Noel's show